every watch I've ever owned has done two
things one quickly given me the time to
looked really nice on my wrist and that
would be why I haven't thought any of
these existing smartwatches sure they're
smarter than my classic analog watches
delivering smart phone notifications and
collecting data about my activity but my
idea of style is not wearing a mini
computer on my wrist
that's why Motorola's $250 moto 360
caught my eye it's the first SmartWatch
actually look like a watch with a round
screen ends a really nice leather strap
it's a big step in the right direction
for smartwatches I just wish it wasn't
literally so big and the Android
software didn't feel so much like
wearing a phone with a stainless steel
frame surrounding the 1.5 inch round LCD
display and a high quality leather band
the watch looks and feels like something
you'd buy at tore know rather than Best
Buy there are a handful of Motorola's
own classic analog watch faces and the
screen is even easy to read outdoors but
the round display isn't a perfect circle
the bottom of the circular screen is
annoyingly chopped off and the problem
for someone like me yes a woman with
small wrists is that it looks like I
just grabbed a [ __ ] off the wall and
stuck it to my wrist of course that's
not the case for everyone on a man with
a medium-sized wrist
it looked decent and on a man with an
even larger wrist it looked just right
motorola does say they're working on
smaller versions that makes me even more
concerned about battery life even this
big honking thing doesn't last long
enough while the watch wirelessly
charges when you put it on this dock you
have to put it on there at least twice a
day excuse me miss do you have the time
let's see my watch died about two hours
ago and the Sun is moved over there so
I'd say about 5:00 p.m. there are a lot
of things I like like how Google now
feeds me information before I know I
need it and I've gotten quite used to
talking to my watch
email Wilson Rothman
but the notification system is still far
too overwhelming
every notification I get on my phone I
get on my wrist also there's a lack of
really useful apps Google's already
fixed some small things and are pushing
improvements straight to the watch and
that's why this watch despite telling
the time better than the others still
tells me it's not the time to buy apples
expected to unveil its wearable soon and
all these other Android wear watch
makers are working on the second
generation of their watches realizing
that one size and one style doesn't fit
all that's why for the time being I'm
gonna stick with my phone in my pocket
and one of these I mean one of these on
my wrist